We Begin today's big celebration and
many Friends reunion at Courtney Cox's
Hollywood Walk of Fame our Denny directo
is there
you are cemented in Hollywood history
how does it feel
s good yeah yeah
to be friends with Courtney is to be
family with Courtney yep Courtney's Walk
of Fame ceremony was a rainy butt warm
and fuzzy Friends reunion let's talk
about court with Jen Aniston and Lisa
Kudrow cracking jokes like they were
back on set my goodness can you step
back
star is straight because that would
really
Lisa joked about Courtney's side hustle
in the mid 90s of course now each start
reportedly makes 20 million a year in
residuals I remember Courtney saying no
but y'all look I've made more money with
the houses than acting and yeah that
changed
backflips that's that slip that was a
good slippery
Courtney also beamed talking about 18
year old daughter Coco who proudly
watched on I just want you to know you
shine and
you shine in your own unique light and I
love you so much I'm so proud of you I'm
proud to be your mom
thank you for enriching our lives with
your work we are so proud of you we love
you your sisters from another mister and
we love you for 30 years 30 years it's a
good thing it wasn't meant to have their
support all these years and also that
Sisterhood you mean they're just
incredible friends and you know I've
known them all for so many years and it
just makes me feel so proud that they
showed up and everything they said I
love them I love them so much
foreign